okay hello everyone it's working alright
so let's start with the old p so a few
years ago this is what the Class B looks
like it was this mess of really
important and nice mathematically nice
problems for which you know some people
showed some algorithms and got stuck on
these algorithms for many years and they
you know they try they give up you know
they moved on to other problems and so
on and we had no kind of we didn't know
any connections between these problems
we didn't know any structure inside the
class p and then we started seeing these
reductions okay so so just when I say
one way to look at this the old p is
that we had all these conjectures each
one of these was a conjecture of its own
the conjecture that you know the current
diagrams are optimal but then we start
doing these reductions and and with
fewer conjectures we actually so because
of these reductions from threesome to
these other problems now you don't even
need the conjectures about the other
problems you can just assume that
threesome cannot be sold faster then you
immediately get that these other ones
cannot be sold faster and then you can
move on to other problems if you want so
we've seen many examples of threesome
lower bands today and the rest of the
workshop you'll see many examples of
strong eth rubber bands explore bonds
that you get if you assume that C and F
set cannot be sold faster there's also
the a PSP lower bands also all pair
shortest paths what's special about
these that most of the problems in the
class are actually equivalent so if you
solve one of them faster you get faster
algorithms for all of them whereas for
the others other classes solving them a
problem in the class faster only implies
that the corresponding conjecture is
false you know and I think this is a
very nice picture that we're starting
together we're starting to understand
the class p but of course there are many
many more things to do there are many
problems that we still don't have kind
of nice lower bounds for and what I want
to do in this talk is just to tell you
about a little bit about
some of the recent progress that we've
been making the first the first part of
the talk is going to be a conservative
one where I'm going to tell you about
some works where we try to strengthen
the foundation so kind of like the
understanding that we're gaining 4p is
because of these conjectures and these
works that i'll tell you about try to
get better conjectures conjectures that
are safer that are less likely to be
false and you'll see that you know while
doing this conservative work we're
actually discovering some new phenomena
that i'll tell you about in particular
this very exciting recent work where we
show that even shaving log factors can
be hard for some problems which i will
tell you a lot about on wednesday and
then in the second part of the talk will
be more liberal and we're actually going
to i'm going to tell you about a new
conjecture that we make that allows us
to explain many many other important
problems and then if you have time the
last part i'm going to tell you about
some approaches for bypassing the lower
bounds okay so so let's start so why why
do we need better conjectures well
because these conjectures you know we
find implausible but we don't really
have any amazing consequences that would
happen if they turned out to be false so
if we solve threesome faster than what
would happen we don't really have many
results that that show surprising
consequences of these conjectures being
false so you know one way to get a
better foundation would be to get more
of these results but what we do is
something a bit different we we just try
to replace these conjectures with better
ones and in this paper with virginia and
watching we look at this new conjecture
which takes these three popular
conjectures and assumes that at least
one of them is true so to refute our new
conjecture you have to refute all three
of them so you have to solve all three
of set threesome and open source pass
faster and can the main result in our
work was that
there are actually nice simple problems
that have tight lower bounds under this
new conjecture so there are some
problems you can solve an N cube time
and if you solve the faster than that
you refute the three conjectures and
these problems are so simple that you
can then reduce them to other important
problems so let me let me show you one
example of one of these problems so it's
a very very hard and cubed problem it's
a problem about triangles in a graph
you're the input is a is a graph in
which every node has a color and you're
also given some integer Delta and the
question is so I ask you is there a
triple of colors that have at least
Delta triangles in them what does it
mean so if so when you look at a triple
of colors like blue green red you see
some number of triangles so here in this
picture you see 2 triangles and just the
question is is there some triple that
will show you at least Delta triangles
so other like Delta triangles with the
same kind of colors matching colors I
trivial algorithm solves this problem
and cube time just going over all
triples of nodes gives you an cubed and
what we show is that if you solve the
problem and enter the 2.99 time then all
three conjectures would be false and to
get a bit of intuition about this
problem notice that when Delta is one if
I always ask you with the question when
Delta is one then I'm just asking you if
there's any triangle in the graph I'm
sure asking is there a triple with some
triangle and then you can solve it
faster with matrix multiplication in sub
cubic time so it's natural to ask so
what happens when Delta is too we
thought about this and we came up with
algorithms that solve it in true is a
cubic time for any constant Delta and
then notice that our lower bounds are
also super quadratic when for any
constant Delta more than 6 and what this
means is that we get this hierarchy of
problems with complexity between N
squared + n cubed so the question of ten
matching triangles has got some
complexity in some interval like say
around into the 2.1 but then the 100
matching triangles problem has complex
tina like
later interval between N squared and X
cube I think this is a nice phenomena
that like we noticed well while working
on this this project okay so that was
the the first work that I want to tell
you about the second one I'm just gonna
go over it quickly because I'm going to
talk about 4 45 minutes on Wednesday so
at this work we look at the strong g th
and the strong g th lower bounds so
we've in recent years we're seeing so
many of these strong bth lower bounds
that are really great they're from all
over computer science you know recent
examples from economics for a sink
stable matching problem and we're what
we're doing this work is that we look at
this class and we find the subclass of
it some some of its coolest problems
like at the distance in LCS and we show
that they're actually harder than what
you thought and so what do I mean by
that so we look at at set and then set
in a general form gives you your given
some function and you're asked if the
function is satisfiable now depending on
the representation of this function
depending on how complex this
representation is it's going to be
harder or easier for you you know if I
give you you know simple things like
DNFs or see NFS it should be easier to
figure out if this thing I gave you
satisfiable then when I give you a you
know as complex circuit like poly log
depth circuit or complicated the Turing
machine and what the the strongest H
says is that even when I give you a CNF
you cannot solve set and 2 minus epsilon
to the end time I know is that this is
kind of the lowest place where you can
put the bar below it we do have faster
than 2 to the N algorithms in particular
for CNF SAT there is 2 to the N over N
to the 1000 algorithms and so the higher
up you go in this hierarchy the more
believable strong ETH becomes so if you
assume that NC circuits Pollock depth
circuits you cannot solve set for them
faster than 2 to the n then you know
this is safe or assumption
and when you go high enough you we don't
even know anything better than two to
the N and so the main question that we
ask is whether we can replace from bth
with the sea strongest yet for a rich
Class C and it wasn't clear from
previous work because the all the
reductions really used that CNF SAR
simple and our main result was that we
go very high in the hierarchy we show
lower bounds under the branching program
strong eth it doesn't matter for now
what it is but point is we we can say
things now that are like if LCS or l
distance can be solvent release of
quadratic time then set on really
complex things like arbitrary circuits
of little o of n depth or very large
boolean formulas can be solved faster
than 2 to the N and a very cool kind of
statement that we make that we can get
because of this new reduction that we
show is that even this might be
subculture cron times even N squared
over locked at some power n will have
big consequences it will imply a new set
algorithms and which will in turn imply
a new circuit lower bands so this might
be a you know difficult and just
remember that for these problems there
are like a log squared shavings and now
you know now it's really interesting to
get this lock to the 1000 down to lock
the 2.1 and you know I'm not gonna
promise anything but maybe on wednesday
i will show you how to do that okay so
that was that was the first part the
conservative part and now now let's
let's try to classify more let's be more
liberal now and you know allow ourselves
more so they're still you know
fundamental problems for which we don't
have lower bounds like Max low and
maximum matching and you know I hope
that by the next Simon's workshop on
this stuff we will have answers for
these problems a really cool result of
the group from San Diego shows that
there might be some barrier for showing
strong eth lower bounds for for these
problems and many others and what this
sort of says is that you
we might have to use new conjectures in
general I mean one might have
optimistically hoped that one conjecture
would explain all of be sort of like in
NP you know one kind of conjecture
explains everything but the kind of the
recent progress is showing that p might
be more interesting than that and we
like different problems might be
actually hard for different reasons and
we might have to use more conjectures so
with that in mind you know hope you let
me introduce this new conjecture from
our paper with the our tours and
Virginia and this conjecture is going to
allow us to give a really cool lower
bound for a very fundamental problem for
parsing the conjecture is going to be
about k click so give you a graph SQ
other k knows that for Mac Nick you can
do a trickle in n to the K time you can
use matrix multiplication and get n to
the Omega K over 3 combinatorially the
best thing that's known as only log
factors better than n to the K and and
what we shows that if you assume that
these algorithms are optimal if you
cannot improve them you know either this
one or that one combinatorially then you
get some cool lower bounds so the
parsing problem that we get a lower
bound for you know to define it I need
to remind you about some definitions
from undergrad so a context-free grammar
is something that looks like this it's a
fine over some alphabet and it defines a
language by you know you start from the
start symbol you apply some arbitrary
sequence of derivation rules until you
get some word and then this word is in
the language of of the grammar so these
languages you know they they have a ton
of applications they represent many many
things and so they're really useful
because they're the most expressive
language is that computers can parse
well and the computational problem that
you know that we're interested in is I
give you a grammar and I give you a
string and ask you can can you get the
string from the grammar so say the
sailor grammars of constant size and the
string of length is of length n you know
how fast can you can you decide if it
belongs to the
Remer and the more kind of standard
parsing problem you you also need to
tell me how you get it from from the
grammar what's the derivation and so you
know a very important question is what
is the time complexity of this problem
and you know many people have tried to
get better algorithms there's a ton of
parsers you know all of them into all of
these ones they take cubic time and on
general grammars when the grammar has
certain properties these things can can
be better or worse you know a classical
partner from the 60 is some kind of
dynamic programming and it gets and
cubes very very simple and a
breakthrough by Leslie valiant from 75
showed that you can kind of do this
dynamic programming with fascinate
matrix multiplication with boolean
mcmullen and you can actually get this
runtime for parsing when you use the
matrix multiplication and when you don't
you can shave Logs with a combinatorial
boolean mesh multiplication algorithm
and this was a very very nice algorithm
and well it's never used in practice
because matrix multiplication is slow
and so this leads to important question
the first one is can we you know first
of all theoretically you know allow a
lower yourself matrix multiplication can
you do better than Valiants parser and
the other question is whether you can
combinatorially beat and cube time and
what we show is that if you want to
believe this cake lick conjecture if you
want to assume that you cannot do better
there's no better argument for K click
then the answer is no to both these
questions and besides parsing we found
out to other problems that are in this
class due to problems that have very
good lower bounds under this quickly
conjecture one of them is RNA folding
from biology so you should they should
pay attention to this class you know the
problem you're working on might have a
lower bound from from k click
okay alright so the last last part of
the talk is going to talk about how you
might try to bypass the lower back so
when you have a you know some I tell you
there's your problem has a lower bound
then you should should ask more
questions right the first thing you
should ask is well can I do a better can
I get a faster algorithm when I allow
approximation and we do have some kind
of simple results that hardness
approximation results in P that follow
from the reductions but for many kind of
really interesting questions we don't
and I feel like we need some new tool
here and my favorite example is inside
the distance so it's not that you can do
a poly log approximation in near linear
time but it's not known I mean the
question is can you get like a constant
factor approximation in truest of
quadratic time so this besides
approximation the second way you can try
to bypass a lower bound is by
restricting the class of inputs so an
interesting open question is can you
solve the ammeter and truly sub
quadratic time on planar graphs it's
known that on general graphs you cannot
under strong eth and these questions of
restricting inputs they are nicely
studied under the parameter eyes
complexity framework so there you you
know you look at some other parameter
besides the size of the input some
parameter k and then you ask what is the
complexity in terms of both k and then
and kind of it's been studied a lot for
np-hard problems but in two recent
papers its proposed to study it even in
p and in our paper we so josh is going
to talk about this paper more on
thursday just to give you one kind of
cool statement that we get so we show
that the diameter in sparse graphs in
which the tree with this k you can get
an upper bound that is kind of F of K
times near linear in n remember you
cannot do a so coach Eric and this
dependence on K is to to do off k lo k
and then we show that this dependence
cannot be improved by much so 2 to the
little o of K would refute strong eth
another example along these lines of
from a different paper with our tours
and thomas and virginia and or we look
at the substratum or vision problem very
very basic question you were given two
trees H&G binary trees and you're a
stiff one is contained in the other and
so you so you're allowed to like swap
children and so on but you need to get h
to be mg so okay first the first thing
we show is that there's a quadratic
lower bound for this on a strong eth and
a matching upper bound there's been
known since the 60s but then we looked
at restricted cases where the depth is
at most h and then so there's a simple
for to the h algorithm and we got this
for down to two point eight five and
then we notice that our lower bond gives
a 2 minus epsilon to the h so if so this
2.85 will not be 1.9 under strong eth
questions
no comment so the reductions themselves
are combinatorial so so for us it's
always been like it doesn't use metric
multiplication it doesn't use fast
matrix multiplication it is not a good
formula zation for it but basically I
mean any formalization that would make
sense is going to transfer from our
reductions is what what we mean by our
lower bands
there are fun of the session conjecture
are there any other candidates that are
we not make sense to consider as a
bachelor conjectures so josh is also
going to talk about the hitting set
conjecture which is essentially a
variant of strong eth where you change
the quantifiers and again the work of
the san diego group shows that the
conjecture might be necessary because
there's a barrier for basing it on
strong eth and one example of a lower
bond that follows from this conjecture
is for radius the radius of a sparse
graph
but yeah it for other kind of problems
like max flow maximum matching you know
very different conjectures might be
needed it's like usually that muscle is
not any linear time I'm wondering why or
yeah okay maybe a better candidate would
be linear programming or maybe maximum
matching on general graphs yeah it's
just you and you know until we find a
linear time algorithm we should be
thinking about a lower bound
any other